from Young Leonard to a show about
Penny's Journey as a new mother fans of
The Big Bang Theory have all kinds of
ideas about what the upcoming spin-off
should be about here's what they're
saying the Big Bang Theory is returning
to television kind of according to the
Hollywood Reporter during a press event
for tons of different Warner Brothers
properties it was announced at Max the
streamer formerly known as HBO Max will
be home to a brand new Big Bang Theory
spin-off Chuck Laurie who created the
original for CBS alongside bill prady
will also be involved Max has been the
exclusive streaming home of the Big Bang
Theory for a while now so this doesn't
come as a shock whether or not there's
more ground to cover in The Big Bang
Theory Cinematic Universe is a question
though oh good they use my NASA picture
whatever this show we'll cover is up in
the air and Lori and his team are
remaining tight-lipped but back in 2019
he did tell The Hollywood Reporter he
was open to spin-offs truthfully the
reason for a spin-off is economics and
that's not the reason to do a show you
should do a show because you have
something you really love and you want
to do it economics follow passion if you
start with economics well become a
network executive obviously there's
already one big bang spin-off which is
if apparent results of Chuck Laurie
walking into the main CBS office and
simply pitching what if Sheldon but
young since 2017 young Sheldon has been
an enormous hit for the network and now
Max will have their own potential Lorry
hit on their hands there's any range of
things this spin-off could focus on
perhaps a younger version of a different
character like Howard Wolowitz in
college Lori did rule out a spin-off of
Leonard and Penny Hofstadter's journey
into Parenthood after Penny discovered
she was pregnant in the series finale my
head is wrapped
something else have been wrapped
wouldn't be in this situation back in
2019 Lori told The Hollywood Reporter no
I feel like these seven characters share
seven different areas of the same brain
we have split them off in every single
different division you can and it all
works there's no two that don't work
together I don't think it would be a
disaster but it wouldn't be big bang
considering how out of the blue news of
yet another Big Bang Theory show was it
only makes sense that it is elicited
strong reactions folks have rushed to
social media to share their feelings on
the impending spin-off and suffice to
say the online masses have mixed
feelings one person wrote on Twitter I
love this show but like why
and it's done yep we're all in all right
I'll see you guys in 20 years and this
person isn't the only one asking that
question numerous people are questioning
why there needs to be another entry in
The Big Bang Theory franchise another
fan wrote on Twitter that they are more
than happy with leaving the franchise
behind once young Sheldon concludes
meanwhile one Twitter user among many
others can't hide their disappointment
over the seemingly endless stream of
sequels prequels and reboots that plague
modern Hollywood as a whole
foreign
at the same time there are quite a few
people who voiced their support for the
new show for example a big bang fan
wrote on Twitter that they're hopeful
that the series could follow Penny's
younger years with Katie Seagal back as
her mother another Twitter user came up
with a pitch of their own for a program
dedicated to Penny's goofy ex Zach
Johnson how can you bounced stuff off
the moon there's no gravity meanwhile
another person wrote on the social media
site that the new Big Bang spin-off is
coming together in response to the
success of young Sheldon so they tossed
out the idea of having it focus on
Leonard's childhood
[Music]